this is a Shantanu my eggs hurt him  somehow the chairman Zayn Malik might  want to listen up  Perry Edward seems to have a message for  her former fiancee and she delivered it  on Sunday's episode of The X Factor UK  little Mix's new single is called shout  out to my ex and the keshe empowerment  ballot is all about going on to bigger  and better things after a breakup after  a four-year relationship two years  engaged Perry and Zayn split up in 2015  now he's dating supermodel Gigi Hadid  little Mix's fourth studio album glory  days is out on November 18th and you can  see the girls perform live on Ariana  Grande's dangerous woman tour in 2017  you